- [Reporter] COVID-19 has caused a surge
in global unemployment like
we've never seen before.
But in the U.S. jobs
have disappeared faster
than in any other developed country.
And then in May America's
unemployment rate began to rebound
while in other developed nations,
it remained relatively stable.
- The U.S. also creates a ton of jobs
because it's easier to fire people.
Businesses are more
confident to hire people.
So you'd expect that the
flexible labor markets
to move more, I suppose, in
response to changes in demand.
- [Reporter] In May and June,
the U.S. added about 7.5 million jobs
but the unemployment rate is
still at the highest level
since the depression.
As the pandemic has put
us in uncharted territory,
we wanted to know, will American jobs
bounce back faster than
the rest of the world?
First, it's important to understand
what difference a flexible
labor market can make.
- In Europe, there's more of a sense that
the company has to have
a very strong reason
to be able to fire someone,
whereas in the U.S.
I think it's much more of a
normal part of a business.
- [Reporter] A flexible labor
market has its pros and cons
and proponents say in normal times,
it helps keep unemployment low
by making it easy for
people to move between jobs.
Just look at the difference
in how long people stay at their jobs
in the U.S. versus Germany.
- It's a different
mentality that in Germany,
it's not a job for life,
but the average employment
tenure is 10 years
at a single company, compared
with 4.2, I think it is,
in the U S.
- [Reporter] After the
2008 financial crisis,
the U S unemployment rate
recovered faster than Europe's,
which also went through a debt crisis.
So, it makes sense that a
more flexible labor market
would see a bigger jump in
unemployment during a recession,
since it's easier for
companies to lay off employees
when demand falls.
But if you look at what happened
at the start of the pandemic,
you'll see two very different outcomes
for two job markets
economist deemed flexible.
The U.S. saw unemployment rise,
roughly 11 percentage
points from January to April
while Japan's unemployment rate
grew half a percentage point.
That's where different
pandemic strategies come in.
In short, the U.S. chose to
give money directly to workers
while the economy reboots,
while others like Japan and Europe
opted to subsidize
companies and protect jobs.
- Canada and the U.S. I think
have been among the ones
that have seen the biggest jump.
The main reason I suppose, is because
they've tried to protect
workers rather than jobs.
They haven't gone for
these job furlough schemes
on a grand scale as the Europeans have.
- [Reporter] As part of
its first stimulus package,
lawmakers sent Americans a
$1,200 one time stimulus cheque
and added $600 a week to
unemployment benefits,
effectively accepting
a wave of job losses.
They also funded key
industries like aviation
to try and prevent or delay some layoffs.
Meanwhile, Japan's government
allocated nearly $700 billion
to business financing
and enacted a program
to subsidize up to around
$140 a day in wages
for furloughed employees.
The EU has invested roughly $120 billion
in similar short term work schemes.
Since those employees
are still on the books,
even if they're not working,
they're not counted as unemployed.
That works well for those lucky enough
to have a permanent job,
but it comes at the cost
of very high unemployment
for young people in some countries
or those on temporary contracts.
- I speak to people on furlough
and yeah, it's essentially a holiday.
Obviously there's nervousness
that is concerned about the pandemic,
but people are spending
their time doing sports
or meeting the friends.
It's a very different experience
being without work in Europe
at the moment than in the U.S.
- [Reporter] But the question
is, how long can it last?
- The labor cost is only part
of what companies are paying.
But you still have to
pay for the premises,
and there's other fees
that you have to pay,
and you've got no income.
So at some point you'll
still have to pull the plug
and let those employees go.
- [Reporter] That breaking point
is going to depend on how
fast economies can recover.
The longer the pandemic drags on,
the more companies could go bust,
erasing jobs that likely
won't be immediately replaced.
In June, the IMF projected
the global economy
to grow 5.4% next year,
but said recovery is still uncertain.
- In the next two or three years,
we'll see which response was better,
but traditionally the U.S. labor market
has been much more dynamic
in kind of reallocating
to growth industries.
- [Reporter] Just look at
how the us stock market
has outperformed Japan and Europe.
Some big American companies
have done really well
throughout the pandemic.
And there are high hopes
that the companies that have done well
will decide to create jobs
while Europe and Japan
have kept unemployment rates
relatively stable so far,
they risked supporting jobs
that might not be as valuable
by the time the pandemic ends.
Think aviation or German auto workers
producing parts for engines
that will likely be phased out.
- Would you wanna have
exactly the same jobs in place
two years down the line? Probably not.
- [Reporter] Germany recently
allocated $12 billion
to expand its job support
program until the end of 2021.
But the future of us business
support is still unclear
as lawmakers have to regularly
assess and approve stimulus packages.
- There's just so much uncertainty
about how long this is gonna last.
The next big debate is gonna
be about the exit strategy
and how to phase out
some of these programs.
- [Reporter] Even if the
U.S. unemployment rate
keeps falling,
the CBO predicts it'll
take more than a decade
to reach pre pandemic levels.
While other developed countries
haven't made such
longterm projections yet,
the ECB forecast that
unemployment in the Eurozone
will still be above pre
pandemic levels in 2022.
A full economic recovery
from this pandemic
is going to take years.
And by the time it's all over,
we may be looking at very
different labor markets
around the world.